[Music]
Red Dead Redemption 2 is a ridiculously
detailed game so we've come up with
about 50 little details that we're gonna
try to get through in under 3 minutes
wait ready on time you can get your hair
and beard super long with hair tonic if
you never take a bath and this scrimshaw
will complain music changes when you do
something dishonorable you can't make
your hair longer at the barber you have
to grow gradually vultures will Peck out
the eyes of corpses you can pet dogs but
not cats
you can tame a wild horse at your first
horse follow you Arthur draws pictures
in a journal of every new animal and
plant you find he'll also draw a picture
of it on the map where you found it you
can hide from bounty hunters in a bush
sometimes a bush method doesn't work you
can steal people's hats your horse can
get scared of predators bare feet will
sound different than boots on hardwood
floors when you jump in the water your
shirt will show how deep you went in
while driving a train Arthur will
physically pull a cord to ring the bell
or tooth the horn the horse will take a
dump once in a while foliage will Bend
and sway in the right direction as you
move through it I love trees horse poo
gets flattened when you step on it or
when you fall in it rain will wash away
the mud on your clothes towns folk will
yell at you if you ride into town too
fast you can jump off a rooftop onto
your horse if you have an expensive
horse people will comment on it
there are tons of great logos from the
Indian companies if you carry a body
with bullet wounds your shirt will get
bloodstains on it
DoubleTap l1 and you'll spin your gun
before putting it away our thirties look
of horror during some disgusting
situations you can see bruises on
Arthur's face when he gets punched
tracks in snow or mud will remain there
if you have a male horse
Arthur calls a boy you are if you have a
girl one he calls a girl that's my girl
if you deplete your cores Arthur will
look visibly tired if you mail a stone
with a bow and arrow equipped you'll
stab them in the head after a storm your
camps grounds will have puddles Arthur
will sing when he's drunk you can fish
with dynamite dive in the sand you'll
leave a bunch of divots if you start a
fire indoors it'll spread to other
flammable objects sprinting into doors
will shatter the glass windows this guy
playing the banjo
this one is not really detail I just
really like howling - the music is
loading screens will always show the
right time of day putting a skinned
animal on your horse will make it all
bloody yeah the moon and the stars in
the sky will rotate throughout the night
you can watch whole shows in the theatre
and heckle them get a fancy gun and
you'll draw the attention every gang
members Arthur that was 47 we didn't
quite make it a 50 but how do we do
that's all we got for this episode of
quick-draw if you have more details that
you wanna share leave them in the
comments below and we'll see you next
week
[Music]
you